en équipe de france les parisiens ont la
cote appelé pour compenser le forfait de
lassana diarra clément chantôme est le
cinquième joueur du psg a intégré le
groupe france avant le japon et
l'espagne et le nouveau bleu n'est pas
dépaysé pour une première c'est toujours
mieux d'être d'être encadrés par des
parts des gars que je côtoie au
quotidien
après avec les espoirs j'en ai connu pas
mal qui sont qui sont là aujourd'hui
donc je me suis pas senti perdu en
arrivant ici le célèbre écart de niveau
entre le club et la sélection ne semble
pas pour l'instant perturber le joueur
de la capitale autre preuve que le club
yvelinois est passé dans une autre
dimension depuis l'arrivée des qataris
le compare avec marie c'est sûr que
c'est à peu près la même chose c'est
paris c'est
quasiment 90% atteint ce n'est donc à
l'entraînement c'est à peu près le même
niveau lors de l'entraînement ce
mercredi clément chantôme ne faisait pas
partie des probables titulaires pour le
match face au japon mais il connaîtra
sûrement sa première sélection avant
d'affronter les espagnols mardi très
certainement le match de ces
éliminatoires
ça va être compliqué là bas mais il
faudra aller il faudra les jouer là bas
cela c'est de faire le maximum courir
pendant 90 minutes comme
des fous sur le terrain défendent sans
semble poser dessus ensemble quoi qu'il
arrive cette présence parisienne en
équipe de france a toutes les chances de
durer déjà parce que les parisiens
vivent au quotidien les exigences de
résultats d'un club ambitieux mais aussi
grâce à leurs automatismes si important
une époque où les sélections les plus
performantes comme l'espagne s'appuient
souvent sur le saturn un club